all right welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules and
Logistics first of all please mute
yourself during the talk unless you have
questions if you have questions you are
welcome to meet yourself and ask those
questions otherwise please use chat room
to post your questions so that we can
address them in Q a session at the end
second today is ddps seminar is open to
external audiences finally The Talk
today will be recorded and uploaded in
our YouTube channel that's about it now
let me introduce our speaker today it is
an honor to host Professor dongbin XU
who is a professor in the Department of
Mathematics of the Ohio State University
he received his PhD degree
from division of Applied Mathematics of
Brown University in 2004 he conducted
postdoctoral studies in Los Alamos
National Laboratory Princeton University
and Brown University people joining the
Department of Mathematics of Purdue
University as an assistant professor in
the fall of 2005. he was promoted to the
rank of associate professor in 2009 and
to full professor in 2012. in 2013 he
moved to the University of Utah as a
professor in the Department of
Mathematics and scientific Computing and
imaging Institute in 2016 he moved to
the Ohio State University he has
received NSF Courier award in 2007 as
well as a number of teaching awards at
Purdue he had served on the editorial
board of several journals including Siam
Journal of scientific Computing and
journal of computational physics he's
the founding associate editor-in-chief
of the international journal for
uncertainty quantification and the
founding Editor in Chief of Journal of
machine learning for modeling and
Computing his research focuses on
developing efficient numerical
algorithms for uncertainty
quantification
stochastic Computing and machine
learning today dongbin will present an
exciting exciting topic which is
data-driven modeling of unknown systems
with deep neural network please enjoy
and expect a wonderful talk now without
further Ado let me pass the button to
don't be in by asking one random
question as usual
um today's random question is what is
your favorite season
um from postseason
oh okay ah
well I guess
I don't really have a strong preference
but uh maybe four because where the user
is lovely during the fall nice in Ohio
yes I'm pretty sure I've been too far
it's always Pleasant I think nice all
right stage is yours all right thank you
Dr Troy for the for the kind of
introduction and also for the for the
invite I'm very happy to be here today
uh to share some of our research in the
last few years as the title says this is
about data through the modeling of
unknown system with deep neural networks
so but I would like to make a point
throughout my talk that the neural
network is deep neural net is a very
powerful tool we use but what we are
going to present is a fundamentally is a
methodology that in principle you can
use some other techniques but deep
neural is very very powerful and I'm a
big fan of neural network so let me
start with some motivation this is
preaching for the choir
um this is something people might of my
friends according in National Labs are
very very familiar with that's that is
how to analyze and predict the behavior
of very very complex system like here I
just borrow a few slides picture from
the web and also some from my colleague
in the past uh this complex system that
is our primary goal for complex for
scientific Computing and they have
gotten so complex that we need to
incorporate many many physical laws or
mathematical models and most of them
have very famous people's name attached
to them because they are very well
established mathematical equations to
describe and govern uh with a very high
fidelity of certain physical phenomena
for example name is equation for basic
fluid flow right and when we deal with
very complex systems like that the
climate will be the ultimate example and
our approach has always been to let's
try to incorporate as many equations as
possible as more more physics as
possible and as a result and our model
eventually gets more and more complex
the point I would like to
emphasize here is what I would like to
call we have reached the circle a point
of diminishing return that is by simply
adding more physics and more equations
to the model does not necessarily buy us
too much yes we sometimes we see a
little Improvement maybe 10 percent in
fact 10 is a lot sometimes we barely see
any and at the end of day as model gets
that models become more and more time
consuming and we end up with things like
this this is random picture put from CNN
one of the hurricane forecast models in
fact there are many many models here and
I'm sure as you are aware of each one of
these curves are produced by highly
highly sophisticated computational
expensive models but at the end of the
day when we have prediction like that
what do we do about them uh is it
conceivable even possible that by adding
even more equations uh including small
terms in each one of this model maybe
some of them will convert the physical
shoes to be honest at this moment that
answer is not that clear right so that
brings us that short motivation brings
us to the topic of so-called data driven
modeling and the same message has been
made by many research in the past few
years that is it has always been data
driven right so in the past is in fact
especially for us it's best people in
multiple myself included that we tend to
think model As Nice equations but we
sometimes forget
why where the equations came from in the
first place they came from a long time
observations sometimes take decades or
even centuries of observation and at
some points on Smart brilliant mind came
into play and they came out with nice
equations of course the name after them
and then we use this equation these are
the models we are familiar with to
predict and analyze the behavior of the
system
of course what we have already accepted
that we are not able to solve all the
equation these are simple enough but
most models mathematical models we have
today are so complicated and that's why
we use computer and that's the whole
discipline of scientific Computing and
so this what I will argue so these days
when we talk in the model the real model
is in fact a piece of computer code it's
a software and it's after all our
discretization of the mathemat no matter
how beautiful the equations are we still
need to disretire them we need to
approximate them and maybe along the way
we even introduce a bug here and there
in our computer code but essentially at
the end of the day what's inside the
computer is what we have to rely upon to
predict and analyze the underlying
physics so the whole idea of data driven
model is that upon realizing this part
we can use computer to help us solve the
equation and realizing again our brain
is not sufficient large enough to come
up with a nice equation why don't we
take this all the way let's come from
the data let's just use the data to
drive somehow get a piece of software
and that as a model that we can execute
and eventually let's just use this model
to predict and analyze the underlying
physics so that's whole idea of data
driven models just to bypass human as
much as possible so having said all that
let me be a little bit more concrete
about what I want to talk about in this
about our research here the data driven
modeling so our focus is in both
basically on dynamic system so let's
assume that I we have
time history of data that's we will call
this trajectory of data over a certain
time in the body we can have many many
of them and we don't know the laws
behind the Dynamics we don't do not have
the government equation if we do have
the equation that by all means go ahead
and solve them what we want to do is
that using this trajectory data the the
time history to come up with a sort of
recursive model that we can March
forward and predict this would be the
model prediction the choose evaluate
evaluated at the same time is let's
choose such as our model prediction is
the numerical model its approximation
would be a very good approximation to
the physical truth and if we have this
model it's as if we have the equation
and we can discretize it and it's a
disquietal equation but we never will
we're not we're not really in most cases
can we cannot write down the mathematic
equation but we do have this numerical
scheme that can
accomplish what we want to do which is
prediction of the future so here we'll
talk about prediction
I want to make a few very important
remarks uh two of them are very
important one is that and I would
emphasize in the next slides as well we
even though the time is the data we have
has time in there we will by all means
do not we do not want to incorporate
time as input variable
and that is we try not to approximate X
as a function of time why the reason is
simple if we try to approximate the
function as access function time this
will be our training data or what we see
and yes we based on this we can come up
with a nice case nice approximation of X
of T but our goal is prediction the
prediction will go Way Beyond whatever
we have observed in our training data
and so if our approximates are coming
from this we will always be
extrapolating beyond what we observe no
method is reliable when we extrapolate
so that's the point I want to make that
we will never try to
think of X as function time as a
conversely here we only think of X as a
progressive recursive iteration over
time so time will now come into play
second what we observe X may not be the
entire complete set of variables in the
system so we do not know the system in
the equation but to make matter what we
may not be able to observe observe
everything again climate maybe the
automated example we can measure you
know when uh pressure temperature a few
variables but the entire column system
made that if there is a closed
mathematic model we may involve let's
say 10 000 variables we do not have that
we can only measure a few so this is a
very big challenge that's also something
we try to observe or we try to tackle
what if what we observe the Dynamics
data is only a small subset of the
entire system which we don't have the
equation in the first place all right so
having said that let me uh come back to
the part of we do not want time variable
in this so this will be an example for
the methodology I would describe in a
moment we only need short burst of
trajectory data time history data so you
can take the so this will be example of
I say I need eight points along a Time
history so you can put this out from a
single long management data file you can
pull multiple pieces here uh you and it
doesn't really matter what it is so at
the end of the day we're going to
collect them into a set of measurement
of length of eight let's call this our
training data and you can collect let's
say 10 000 many of them if you have long
treasure that treasure data time history
you can do a lot of segments out of this
thing
um so we would prefer them to be from
different projects but that's uh
important and yet mind a secondary
concern the most important thing is that
we would next thing we do we will remove
the time variable a simple thing we just
drop them all right so by dropping them
we will not know when exactly this
trajectory occurred in time as opposed
to goes in here all we see are the
segments of traject times of eight
entries and they are they are occur at a
different time doesn't really matter to
us all we carry that we only have each
one of them is as if they start with the
initial condition and mass forward seven
times that's all we care okay so by
doing so we will remove the time
variable also it makes data acquisition
collection much easier you don't need to
record the time you just need to record
the relative time so that's what we do
here that's that's in fact very easy
thing to accomplish
having said that let me give the example
how this can come into play so this will
be very similar to what I just
Illustrated earlier suppose I have time
history this you will be example of
so-called glucose induced insulin
oscillation which is as many of you may
be aware are very relevant to a diabetes
study let's assume that we have
measurement of insulin response after
injection for certain individual I have
exactly 0 to 15 16 points I do not care
about time there's only 16 points
separated by times of 0.05 certain unit
I don't do not know exactly what time
this is but this is only 16 points after
initial points and also I have this
response at certain so-called Baseline
glucose level is a single constant
parameter every individual have a
glucose level for me sitting here I have
a glucose level if I have a meal my
glucose level would be different at
different level if I go on exercise this
number will be different it's a constant
is an initial constant let's just say we
can collect this kind of data that the
different glucose level after injection
the short time response offers against 0
to 15 only 16 points of this time time
step let's say we can collect many of
them okay and uh it turns out people can
collect a lot of data about uh diabetes
but assume this is the only thing we
have we only have at the different
parameter based on glucose parameter
level I have the early response of
insulin we ask the questions can we view
the model and understand the very long
time behavior of this incident what what
happened after this early stage so
that's what we're going to do so let's
try to do a data driven thing we don't
do not have equation for that
um so what we based on what we have I'm
going to use a neural network and at the
input I'm going to throw this single
parameter into one node and for the
measurement data from 0 to 15 I'm going
to throw the 0 to 14 to the early nodes
so I have this will be 15 plus one
seeking inputs I will use a very last
one as
reinforce the output that's why we
compute the mean square error to match
the output to the 15th the last entry of
my management data but in between will
connect a very simple fully connected
feed forward Network right so and then
we have all this data
and you do a neurons extremely I'm sure
many of you are familiar how this goes
to a minibus whatever automatization
through this intensive flow or Pi torch
at the end of the day once we've enforce
this means we're a lot to a certain
level we call this method Converse All
right so this is what we then we have
neural network create a model this model
was given a initial parameter g0 given 0
to 14 input I can recursive go forward
in time get 15 then I can move 15 here I
slide everything backwards and I can get
16 I can recursively go forward in time
for as long as I want to so this can
give me a long time behavior of the
insulin but the difference that we have
now created a data-driven sort of a
scalar model that doesn't require a
knowledge of any other variables that's
involved in this as you what you can
imagine very complex math biology
problem so the question is that we can
always train Network and model the
question how good this is so let's do
some data Asian and plot a few other
initial structures 0 to 15 same setting
as before at the different glucose level
each one and we can feed them into the
network neural network model we just
created is the one model we created will
never touch it again we only execute on
the different circumlets so let's fit
this initial y a correspond to g010 put
this into initial condition marks this
forward in time for much longer time
this is the result we get everything of
the circle the circle would be what we
feed into the network everything
afterwards would be the prediction by
Network itself as you can see the
network prediction will be the blue very
close to the truth I will tell you in a
moment what choose is you can see the
agreement is quite well and it's Rich
statistic state which is obviously not
very obvious from what we can observe on
the initial Evolution right this goes
steady state pick another curve 1.1 and
the system again after in this condition
the predicts by the network itself again
goes to steady state with some
oscillation earlier take another curve
and yes against steady state and then
also also this become a little more
obvious at early stage another curve 1.3
other certain the neuronic versus is a
periodic state which is the match the
truth and again everything at the circle
is pure predicts no data anymore and
makes a different g0 level this become
even bigger oscillation all right so and
you can see the match with the so-called
truth here is very very close and now
that we have this scalar model for
single variable insulin for its long
time Dynamic we can analyze that and now
we see this accurate enough I can play
God mode we can just simply interrogate
this model to get all kinds of behavior
out of this one thing people study in
this phenomena is that people already
know that g0 the single parameter pre
plays the key role in determining the
long-term behavioral system so in here
it's a steady state and here is the
periodic state so what you people do
with that they just record the Max and
mean of the when the system reaches the
stable State and here maximum would be
the same number here Max will be above
here means here and you plot this Max
mean against the single parameter you
get this kind of by application diagram
when g0 is quite small we have a steady
state Max and B match each other and
when G zeros passes the threshold it
become a periodic State and the
amplitude would become bigger and bigger
and bigger and all of a sudden are
passing here the system returns to the
steady state again so it's quite
interesting Behavior once again these
are blue curve blue dots are produced by
just interrogating this neural net model
and the red is the truth okay so we can
also do things like uh with different g0
single parameter and the systems
responsible different then if I have a
meal my g0 will be at a different level
the response would be different if I
have another dessert and my t0 uh gets
higher and higher anyway this is this
can result people uh invested in the
literature so having once again you can
see here the the neural net model has
very remarkable accuracy compared to the
truth and what is the truth here we
don't really have real data the choose
in our case are is produced by synthetic
data they are coming from this so the
whole thing is about insulin response
it's in some very complex math biology
system I wish I have no idea about what
we did that would there are several
models to study this insulin response uh
so we put this one from one well
established textbook it's reasonably
complex with this bifurcation B here
this is the true model we use and has 4
four state variables and about 16
parameters we put all the parameters
from the book everything used standard
from textbook what we did that we solved
this system with these parameters with
Matlab with accuracy but we record for
Network purpose we record only two
things Y is it Z this g0 this single
parameter in our modeling the other one
is the early response of I that's 0 to
15 the first 16 entries of the response
everything else from the model we throw
them away they are never recorded as if
we don't know so this is just pretend in
the real world we can only measure this
and the early response of this based on
this little thing you can see the neural
network can build a model that analyze
the long-time behavior of I without any
knowledge of any other variables
whatsoever okay the introduction
everything you basically as if I have no
idea how these physics involve what
variables involved I just what do I see
and what we model that's so I hope by
this by this example at least is uh
shows you that the you know it suggests
that it is possible now that we can
build very accurate model and close by
itself and this closed main system
closed this is the closed system right
everything defined each other but
self-close mode for only a subset of
variable which in this case there is not
a single mathematical model to govern
the evolution I we have to rely on other
variables for the data driven modeling
it doesn't require that
so having said that like I said uh when
we have this data we throw them into a
network it's not a random choice we make
in fact this work was a result of a
several about four or five years uh
development over over this year when in
fact the example is in none of these
papers uh when we try the example we
actually know there is no way it does
not or it has to work it turns out to be
one of the easiest examples to Trend and
to get high accuracy so so this is what
I want to talk to you about this
so-called method so-called flow map uh
learning I just call this FML how it
works and how it makes gets us to the
modeling of the sofa only a single
variable in a much much bigger system so
again this is the setting so just 10
seconds of neural network we do not
require any special uses of any special
structure of neural network all we use
that neural network does at the end of
the day is a mapping from input to
Output in this case would be input map
to 8 R8 to four variables R4 and in
between almost all our works we simply
use fully connect feed forward network
with nothing special user usually value
as activation function and sometimes we
use 10 H and we didn't use any of this
this turns out there's no need for any
of the special Network
so let me come back to uh the basic
settings so now let's let me start with
a simpler system simple problem that is
I have a dynamic system that we do not
know the governing equation right so but
we do have observation of X so we
observe every variable in the system so
this will be the evolution of X and
again from the time history will pause
trajectory out of this that's our
training data
it's a very very busy field of so-called
data-driven uh equation recovery that is
with the measurement time case of X
let's try to recover F uh we do not do
that in fact we have the equation we had
some early work on that as well in this
work we do not try to recover F at the
point being that what if we recover f
um with some error I mean f looks most
likely is non-linear we still need to
discretize it and make it into a
computer code algorithm so here let's
not try to do that let's again like I
said let's do it in one shot we want to
create a model directory in one step so
we try to approximate the underlying
flow map that's why where the name came
from for the method what is flow map
flow map is simple Concept in dynamic
system is simply the mapping between
Solutions one stage t0 can be any time
to another state t so this is the
mapping will parameterize
oh
what what do I
do you see something something at me is
right do you still need admin rights I
just click ask X yes anyway
hopefully I don't drop anyway
um so
the mapping is just in a pretty map
solution from one time to another time
for autonomous system like this only
time difference method that's key thing
so time doesn't really matter so let's
to look at any ins any solution from
data from one instant to the next and
they're all separate let's assume the
time step is constant Delta Delta T so
the mapping this flow map is simply X
map to the current time to the next
stage right so that's current by exactly
same map covers by the same parameter
which if you assume constant is doesn't
even matter here so this is simply
mapped from RD to Rd and that's what we
can do with any mapping so in this case
we only need two data
from any trajectory so you can pull a
pair consecutive pair anywhere from time
we should pull them out all right so and
then I would just call this the first
one X1 the second one is X2 they're all
relative again time doesn't matter is
only relative relative position
everywhere here is X1 X2 X1 is currently
State uh solution uh X2 is the next uh
one step later and this is parameters by
this map which are the two Rd the
constant becomes we want fund Rd to Rd
let's try to minimize these error so I
would find the map approximately
approximate amount to this such that my
output by my mapping would try to match
the real thing as much as possible mean
Square loss and you if you minimize this
problem it's like everything like
is the least Square problem there's
nothing fancy to that once we find this
mapping and you can now execute given
any X1 you can keep recursive going
forward in time and that will give you
predicts for a long long time it's a d
dimensional function approximate it's
not operator learning that's a key thing
why because you only care about the
function from RD to R the output D
doesn't really matter but as I said it's
not operator learning which is a busy
Topic at these days is simply because
again the fact that I said we did not
ever ever try to write X as function T
if you have a little T inside and become
an operator but now we only look X as a
vector so it's multi-dimensional
coordinate is a function approximation
for low Dimension you can do polynomial
calcium process everything in fact if
these reasons were small I would just
say by all means go with polynomial it
kills the problem with extraordinary
high accuracy that's always in fact our
first paper on this but most likely in
practice D is not very small so neural
network is essential very very powerful
so this is how it works again where if
you insist and we also Advocate use a
neural network and then of course the
network output which is minimal this
error this is very simple fully conduct
feedphone unit this would be a third
friend and you can also do a restaurant
which in our first paper we advocate of
doing that the retina is simply says
this mapping it just doesn't try to map
from input to the output in fact this
part is mapped to the the difference and
as a result we need to do prediction you
have to add this background you can then
that will be the scheme that's only
difference between these two they are
absolutely equivalent mathematically
there's no difference
just plus minus one depending where you
put them
but this resnet structure looks like Ola
forward stepping except it is not over
forward
um that in fact the entire Arrow here
has nothing to do with delta T So this
exact integrated in time there's no
temporary error no explicit dependency
on delta T there are the arrows
basically the minimization of this
training error so in our early work we
have used resnet primarily to uh which I
found this uh computationally Advanced
advantageous but as we gain more and
more experience we have found that you
know this thing requires very high
accuracy at the end of date the resident
doesn't really matter so you it's your
choice whether you use them use it or
not we still keep resonating in most of
our work it's just mostly for from the
Legacy code all right so let me show you
one example again this example has is a
four-dimensional example so my state
variable has U1 U2 V1 V2 sort of OD to
algebraic constraint that's not really
OD right so the mapping as I said would
be R4 to R4 is reasonable low Dimension
let's do in fact this result is produced
by polynomial you do neural network you
have same result all right so and this
is the prediction of the 1000 steps
again the training data is just one
separate by one step you see
extraordinary short time place which is
one step right and I want to make again
an effort is that uh upon you that you
look at this function the V2 response
and V1 as well as a function of time
this extraordinary difficult function to
approximate with the spikes like this
there's always no method that can really
approximate this kind of spikes with
high accuracy fear it is very accurate
why because once again as I said very
beginning we never try to approximate X
as a function of time we only try to
approximate X how it evolved over one
step as a function all right so once you
get every one step correct it is
eventually will produce the correct
function over time this is exactly how
any time indicator Max uh works if you
knew the equation you can solve this by
run the quota don't shoot looks exactly
like that except n is well defined from
the equation you know what this is here
we just don't know what the end is we
use data to try to learn this but the
time stepper allows us to go Progressive
in time accurately every step and
eventually it can produce some vastly
compressed Behavior over time but the
function this thing as a function of
time never come into play so that's the
uh again the message I think have
overstating a little bit but again this
is the key feature of this method right
so now let's move on to the very
practical situation that in most cases
we cannot measure every variables in the
entire system so now let's have the
whatever com autonomous system that's a
big complexity that we don't know the
equation we have no idea what the f is
so in fact we probably don't even have
idea how many axis variables we need to
have a f is just we have no idea all
right but we do have is that we can
measure a few a subset of them so Z like
I said in in climate modeling this can
be temperature can be a pressure can be
dense uh density uh or a few things and
everything else W are the missing
variables we may not even know how many
were missing is it is it 5 50 5 000 10
000 missing we have no idea because we
don't know what the complete system look
like but we have let's say you measure
three variables that's all we have the
question we asked based on time history
of these three variables can we build a
model for these three variables only in
principle coming from autonomic system
is is possible there's a so-called very
well known more resounding formulas as
you know this kind of equation does
exist
in principle it's not useful because it
said the equation look like this this is
my common term this sum integral term
and that's initial condition we don't
know usually treat it as a random
variable so this is not important and
what's not useful is that this formula
is is exact formula but it's only sort
of like existence it doesn't tell us how
to get R how to get in most important is
K the kernel thing okay so uh there has
been a lot work on estimating
approximating kernel k
from here but that's based on the
knowledge we know the letter F in the
first place we are trying to get to K
but here we do not know this anyway so
there's no way we can have K but
nonetheless we're going to use this as a
motivation to design our data-driven
approach all right so the motivation
goes like this you look at this integral
so if we want to know any the evolution
of of Z The Observers at current time
let's call this T this needs to go back
from s equals zero with t naught minus
it would be count time t s goes to T
this T monthly will be zero so this
requires our us to know the solution at
the current time go all the way back to
the initial condition we're going to mix
a very mild but something that yes this
is so-called memory memory doesn't go
very long in most system so we only need
to go back from the current time to some
fixed time all right so you do not need
to know your solution today or tomorrow
you do not need to know everything has
happened through the beginning of the
universe in fact in most cases we go
back to a certain amount of time that's
enough anything further back in in
history do not have any impact on the
current state that's the final memory
assumption which is almost universally
true for any system and of course the
difference is that the key that how long
should we go back and we don't know but
uh that's a problem dependent but let's
assume we can we should only go back
from here back towards final time that's
how we go all right so now this integral
is replaced by this with some negligible
error that's the first milder sums now
that we change this to a final integral
that doesn't depends on T anymore and
which is going to assume for finite
integral we have we have some kind of
approximation method that can compute
this number very accurately based on
small uh threshold based on whatever
data in between these two in between
current time to backtrack the memory
time this again is easy because if we
know the equation we can simply do some
kind of gross quadrature this will be
this exists here of course we do not
know the integral but we always say you
know what a good approximation exists
that's all we need all right having said
both now we see we exchange this to an
approximate formulations that if we
let's call the current time TN if we
want to know the evolution are current
on TN we just need to know this at the
end and this entire integral depends on
everything TN backtrack one step two
step whatever number of steps that
contend in the memory that's how we do
so this is our approx discrete
approximation to the more response
equation based on very mild assumption
and this just tells us
we just need to find this and this but
we don't have this that's what we do
with data driven we just said our FL
model cells in order to know one step in
the future all we need is the current
time step and something go back in time
we need data on this and if we can
create this mapping that's the model
right so the the function approximation
becomes that given this many data so
this will be n map plus one times D the
data to this mapping this will be our
mapping we want to find this and this
will be the network structure if we want
to do all right so find this operator
and this will be example says I I only
need to go back two-step in memory this
current this is the future if we go back
one and two and if you have data if you
have enough data of three mapped one you
have data lengths at least four in your
time history you can create input and
output and you if you have many of these
you tune a network that will be the
model and the model is in fact coming
from very rigorous derivation so as I
said here this
relationship here has nothing to do with
neural network neural network is just a
way to try to create this operator n
right so anyway so this will be the
example I showed you earlier like the
instant example goes from 0 to 14 and
with the one parameter here and to the
next all right so so the the neural
network mode of the training doesn't
doesn't really give us more results this
method eventually doesn't give it just
gives us a direct predict model that we
can go forward in time how does this
compare to the more results that we
don't know in fact as we're not even
trying to recover more is once again in
this case
so let me show you example that linear
system equations leadership turns out to
be quite difficult to model
um it's
x dot equals ax let's say I have 20
Vector of 20 a is 20 by 20 Matrix we
come up with some random choice of this
a and we can solve them with our
authentic data we assume we don't know
anything about
10 component we have short time
measurement time case of the first 10
component of the X we do nothing about
the 400 parameter in this system we know
nothing about the missing 10 variables
and in fact now you can see that the 10
variables here do not give us a closed
system to solve e always requires notice
of Q right so I we can test in this case
how long is the memory when we create a
memory we need 0.6 let's call this
second so it's very short
trajectory we need we just need to see
many many pieces of this we create a
mapping and then we we're going to
execute
for the prediction of x one to ten
forward in time to go all the way from
zero to 150 very long time prediction
this will be the X3 this will be the X6
all right so and you can see the neural
net model uh which is red compared to
the truth by solving the entire system
and is very very close after this
long-time non-trivial Dynamic so it's
not steady state it's not purely
periodic state is is unclear what state
is but anyway the accuracy is good uh
let's make this a slightly slightly
non-linear so let's deal with a not very
chaotic but not very chaotic it's a fast
slow variable so that x one two three
are the slow variables and Y is a fast
value how fast this depends on how small
absent is
we assume that we can measure through
variable in most cases that's what it
can fast variable too fast we cannot
measure So based on that time Crystal
data of x123 we want to create a model
for the slow variables only so this is
like cost graining homogenization you
name it that's we always try to come up
with the effect model for the slow
variables the course variables in this
particular case we're going to
homogeneous mathematical homologization
uh just get rid of this and that's the
mathematical model which is exact when
Epsilon go to zero right so here let's
fix the case X absolutely is 0.1 so it's
not exactly this is not very accurate
but it's reasonably good uh at the same
time we can use maximum data one two
three let neural network create a model
for x123 or you know homogenized model
and this will be the prediction of let's
see this prediction of X1 from 0 to 200
to 400 I did not plot the first 200
because if I do that everything
cluttered looks like a random noise but
upon code so if you zoom in they're not
random no it's a deterministic chaotic
system so the first 200 plus entirely is
missing the memory is 1.2 that's the
Trinity data we have we just need the
data of x one two three of lens 1.2 this
predicts up to 400 you can see neural
network is the red the truth Computing
from the real system and since that is
the black you can see the red and black
track is a really really really really
well okay and the blue which is a human
created
a homogeneous system in a human
approximate it's not too bad but you can
visually see the difference compared to
the truth if we compute the error over
long time this will be the error by our
human model human creative model right
so the now is from zero to four hundred
this is a typical error Behavior growth
over time nothing surprising this error
by the machine learning closed mode by
neural network the arrow is a lot
smaller and a lot more stable we do not
have a full understanding of the runtime
stability behavior of these neural net
models just because we don't have enough
mathematical tools to understand neural
network but we have seen this kind of
behavior very very often it's the
long-time Behavior stability can often
be
surprised surprising but in a very
pleasant way so
let's make this fully chaotic so it's
nice as much smaller system let's look
at Lawrence 63 so this will be the exact
Lawrence system through which we
generate synthetic data and validation
data and we tried to model only X that
we only have X as a data we create a
scalar mod of X but here I will show you
X and Y because X and Y I can plot in
two dimensional plot so let's pretend
here we have recorded
time case of X and Y only but we know
nothing about Z right so this is the So
based on X and Y we're going to use
neural net this flow map learning to
create a model for X and Y only and is
we need history the history is point one
times that 0.01 so this requires to have
10 step of management data of X and Y
this will be the two dimensional the
neural network model the phase portrait
starts from here this is up to 100 in
fact I think it is more than 100 and
maybe one thousand I forgot
um but anyways long time integration was
and this would be the exact model but
the face part will project on X and Y
the truth you can see visually this is
very good we don't have good point wise
arrow is chaotic system nothing would
track the point-wide error accurately
over a long time it's just natural
chaotic system so here we just look
visually they look quality qualitatively
they are close enough we also based on
this the data we compute a few measure
for the how chaotic the system is the
so-called correlation Dimension
approximate the entropy liability of
exponent there's a number from the
neural net model this is a choose you
can see that the number of reasonable
closed captioning not available
there are two cases first if we can
measure we have times of all these
variables it's a simple case you just
create a one-step mapping your training
data is only one two steps and you can
get a lot of data even though in most
new address training we do ten thousand
twenty thousand history to Trend does
but this ten thousand twenty dollars of
one step data so the in overall data
requirement is in fact very low thinking
about if you do one system prediction
sometimes solve system you can easily go
one million step and you can put a lot
of two-step data from here this is what
it looked like if however what your data
is only partial measurement then that
requires memory and then this will be
the mapping and you have more trim on
the left all right in both cases we
allocate the use of neural network
because the dimension would be high keep
in mind here for example here with
two-step memory is three dimension but
each Z is a vector if Z is a vector ten
this is 30 Dimension so Dimension goes
High very fast so and as I show you
several examples it looks really really
well we just make quick uh remarks that
you can also model system with different
controls and and all excitations the key
of this there's some modifications have
to go into that but at the end of the
day you can do you can train your neural
network model based on some control then
the prediction the control can be
entirely different that's never ever
present in your training data so this is
a very remarkable property we have found
this from this thing by looking at the
one step at a time never have time
involved that allows us to do that so
this paper has the detail on that so I
don't have time on this I won't give you
not just a few minutes a quick uh idea
on how we do this with pde because we
have discussed so much about dynamic
system right
um pde is what people really care about
so now it's a similar setting suppose I
have a set of grid on which I have data
right so the data is my it now is a
field so this is I can think of my
observation as one Vector field as if
this is the final element solver your
grid your grid will be a vector lens
let's say ten thousand if you have ten
thousand nodes in your final item solver
so it's one bigger vector
suppose the autonomous supposedly
observe every View and now it's fully
observed system it's just like audio
and it's nothing is missing so we just
need to
map from current state to One Step later
you have this we can create a map and we
can solve this learn this unknown PD
right turns out it doesn't really work
we we try this many many times no less
than thousand different cases
it just didn't work uh Y is because in
dynamic system the mapping between these
are the state variable X
such as vectors they're components of
vector nothing we can say about it's a
dynamic system for PD is different the
use are solution in space they are not
random components of a vector U has
smoothness and regularity they are
connected in through them because PD has
operated in them so there's a smoothness
regardless in there that we are not
enforcing here that's you know things
when I say they don't work they don't
really not work they just work sort of
inconsistently and without the high
accuracy I've similarly throughout this
work we really demand accuracy to be
high so we eventually find convolution
network still didn't quite work again no
less than a few thousand test cases
still didn't quite work so we eventually
were forced to develop for the first
time a network structure to enforce
something again it was it is motivated
by the mathematics right so suppose I
have a PD like this involves some kind
of differential operator I don't know
what they are I don't know what L is I
don't know how many but I suppose I know
the pde and suppose I have a set of grid
I'm I can solve this by some kind of
older fold I'm not going to do that but
all of our does exist right so one step
mapping from here this will be my
operator and each spiritual would be
replaced by some
differentiation Matrix that's numeric
analysis tells that is everything linear
made through Vector product for
derivatives this would be my very naive
order forward its stability would most
likely be an issue but we're not solving
it we just need this to be on the
conceptual conceptual level it exists it
gives me some kind of truncation error
one step I would just say that since we
don't know this we don't know this
derivative I would just say you know
what we can make every different Matrix
a non-linear operator it doesn't even
need to be linear operation if I make
everything lean non-linear is
incorporate this as a special case so so
the existing Olaf forces that exist an
even bigger class and non-linear scheme
such that my error one step right could
be at least could be smaller it at work
would be like this so it's a special
thing just we're just making this class
of method
or much bigger much broader and we are
saying that the arrow will commit over
one step most likely would be smaller
than this but at the worst case it would
be just like this why because I can
simply put this back into my linear
Matrix that exists so that's all we need
so this I went down we see this
non-linear forward method does exist
like this with some operator we don't
know and this this output correspond to
L this is how we design our neural
network structure the input One Step
input the vector over find element grid
is here the output is here
in between we have a sort of neural
network in parallel goes for it in this
way in parallel in this direction each
one corresponds some kind of linear
Opera without we do not know and then I
have another Network horizontally acting
component wise against all of them
this is a non-linear operator here to
learn the L here and if we connect this
together that I can trim and this one
works consistently in fact without this
layer what we call assembly layer up to
here these days it's resembles
convolution natural very much all right
so this is the key this is what we call
the assembly block the assembly layer is
what really makes everything worse to
enforce regularity things like that let
me quickly show you a few examples
again the equation here only serves the
purpose of generating training data and
validation data so the equation may be
simple okay u t plus u x equals zero the
simplest equation analytically perhaps
the most difficult one to solve
accurately numerically again everything
here just with on rely on one step
Vector at here we have 15 nodes uh it
will be the vector of 50 to 50 mapping
so there's nothing missing just one step
mapping in between have the December
assembly block and this will be you know
predicts over a fairly long time the 20
uh two plus one you can see the accuracy
quite well in fact the dispersion error
is much much better than we expected
many numerical method if you know we
know the equation to solve this by some
standard numerical method at T20 was so
worth this person error but here is just
by learning the equation lesson advising
diffusion doesn't really matter I just
want to show you that it works with
non-uniform Grid in fact this case that
the grid is not only non-uniform they
are also ran normally permuted we do not
this method doesn't require any
knowledge of the physical structure of
the grid the geometric structure
connection is not required you can deal
with higher derivative this is easier
case because in more diffusive diffuse
equations all be easy to simulate uh
integral equation which in fact makes
the effect to make this non-local
problem again is diffusive is very easy
accuracy is good
Burgers equation would be an interesting
example that again in this case when we
generate the training sample we have 50
nodes we solve this by some we actually
don't at the beginning we only we solve
this analytically
and that means that our if our training
data is created by some randomized
Fourier series sine cosines we created
their their final Series so they are
very smooth we solve this by one times
that which is 0.01002 nothing happened
or one times and no shocks whatsoever so
that's opportunity that all else we need
a small sine cosine over one steps which
is also simultaneous upon learning the
operator mapping between the two steps
if you execute this on the new initial
conditions over much longer time when it
the stock will appear it does appear so
that's the thing I would like to
emphasize here again is we do not need
to see the physics in order to predict
the physics in fact in a very if you
recall in the very first instant example
this already showed that none of the
early stage the incident response has
steady see the periodic State you never
see that in training data but the
Overland term the if you have the
correct model it will produce the
correct the physics is always very short
time Dynamic it doesn't have any
interesting fits in the short term you
all ones have almost nothing happens
to make matter a little more interesting
here we assume that we can only observe
grid value at right half in fact 40 of
the domain
and in this case we actually do need to
use memory because these are 50 Vector
50 or we only observe 20 of them so
we're missing 30 component is missing
variable we have memory but with
sufficient number you can still predict
facing here and this accuracy isn't that
high but we say you know what in this
case with shock and 40 domain you know I
will give this a pass so let me just
finish and do two dimensional unstructed
grid this would be two Dimension but uh
this PD but the entire one set of
variable completely wiped out we only
have data we this is very expensive this
is like 50 by 50 grit so the vector will
be 2500 length and with memory I believe
we have 10 memory
um so this will be 25
000 input for the neural network so it's
a little bit expensive but a long-term
prediction the solution goes uh up down
sort of sort of periodic with a little
bit diffusion and you can see see the
reference prediction looks fairly
reasonable so anyway let me finish time
is up
um what I've discussed is what I call
the FML the flow maplin is some method
it's a methodology again I want to
emphasize it's not it shows some
capability that was never really we
didn't really thought about before for
example if we can model only things we
observe so this should be very useful if
we try to do some kind of multi-scale
modeling or try to speed up competition
by only predicting the cost variables
which goes faster or you just blend this
I only see this I model this right so
um without worrying about any other
variable that may or may not coupled
with the things we want model
but this capability if it's new in
certain way like I hope this talk has
Illustrated for you that it's not
because the neural network is simply
because we set up the problem
mathematically correctly and we set it
up at correct mapping from input to the
output neural network is a very very
powerful tool one which I a big fan fan
of but it's not what brings the Magic
The Magic is about setting that properly
and in most cases our network is very
small it's not really deep learning like
this it's not very deep but anyway
um there's no really need to use special
structure the thing with memory one may
ask someone you may ask can you a famous
natural structure that in incorporate
memory is lstm can you do that yes if
you have missing variable if you do lstm
you can accomplish about the same result
we have our collaborator who has tested
this soft extensively but then it's back
to the question in our case if we know
how it works why do we need to introduce
this structure with a gate and
everything either you know is a small
plan Network would get it done so anyway
one big thing I would emphasize is that
and for many of you who have done neural
Life Training uh who who really
buy on the accuracy of things you know
how hard it is to reproduce the result
right it's for students who have trained
that where you train that today tomorrow
it may may not be the same you'll pull a
code from GitHub from some of the paper
and you try to replicate the result you
cannot whose fault it is so in our group
reproduce reproducibility is the number
one criteria a good result about the
result it better be reproducible so all
we're in the process of organizing
almost all the examples I discussed here
in this talk and many of our papers
how to generate the synthetic training
data set in fact the trinidades that we
use which is generally example more
importantly we're going to put the data
we used to plot the plots
so that you can re-plot what we had in
paper immediately and then compare to
your results so uh I'm also in the
process of writing a very detailed uh
paper describing the computational
details the the Arts how to create
reproducible plots so anyway all of this
will be available is in the process of
getting uploaded at the moment I have a
new website that I see in the making but
anyway this will come up in just a few
weeks so with this I will finish and
take some questions thank you thank you
so much for the wonderful talk I enjoyed
it a lot I'm sure everyone else enjoyed
it a lot as well although it's 11 how
let's have a crane session I hope you
have some time yeah I do have some time
so I don't know how to see chat uh yeah
well don't worry about it okay so
Pat are you there are you
still there and you post a lot of
questions and yeah and and yeah just let
let me let's just take the the most
important ones yeah there are other
questions too
um that from other people
um so so you seem to be assuming that
that neural Nets are the way to go here
rather than trying to discover
the equations themselves in some
Interpol form and there has been a lot
of work uh for decades on that approach
um so could you now I mean and of course
there's also been a lot of recent work
on on uh using neural Nets to do similar
kinds of things because could you just
talk about the pros and cons and why you
think that this this doesn't have to be
better right this could be just one
among many approaches but you did
suggest at times that you thought this
would be better than other approaches
including
but implicitly better than learning the
equations directly what's your opinion
on this so yeah so I I I I do I did say
that neon network is very powerful again
like like I said in this but you don't
have to do neural network so you you
want that in in um in all these things
we did here it's just a tool to uh to
accomplish this kind of map so it's just
a way to accomplish this mapping like I
said if the dimension is low
is the king but I I am a fan of neural
network because many of cases the
dimension is very high the infinite
nodes and so let's do new on that so why
do you believe that neural Nets will be
better than say trying to discover the
the equations in classic
ode form so that's uh that's had nothing
so again it's I want to be very clear is
I will advocating getting this off model
neural network can be part of community
like that as opposed to discover F in
the first so we have done similar things
so let's see you won't discover F so
let's just assume you can discover F
analytically correct all right not
analytically I'm talking about inducing
it from the data in the same way you are
with the neural network yes that's what
I'm saying that if you can induce F from
that the first of all you can never
induce F exactly correct you have error
in the first place right and then you
have to D squaredize whatever the
approximately F to solve you induce
another error so error Compound on
itself you're solving the wrong you're
solving sort of slightly the wrong
equation in the first place all right so
just to be clear are you saying that
forget about whether you're doing neural
Nets it sounded as though you rather
than learning a differential equation or
a difference equation yeah whether it's
in neural net or other form that you're
learning a mapping directly from from
the values at one time step to the next
time step correct yes you're not
learning the difference
regardless whether you're where you come
from you come twice recover F to do
other form at the end of the day your
prediction look like this one step to
the next is the mapping so that's what
we just try to go through this one step
mapping in one shot because I want to
use the word one shot there because it's
overloaded it's still the partial means
I have my data I want to create this one
step mapping in one step that's all
right and as opposed to separate the
tasks you will introduce error in
different stages they compound each
other make their weak at each day is X N
plus one equals x some kind of X we
should we should follow up separately
I've got I've got your email address
um someone else had a question about
noise
uh nice uh a very good question noise
there are two kinds of noise one is the
standard measurement or you have if for
example in this slide if I have X1 X2
both have observation noise this is
easier to deal with in the sense that
you just do because at the end of the
day the learning part the the uh the
things I discussed here is really about
minimizing the mean square error so
let's just do this yeah so it's about
minimizing the mean square error so we
know is the least square is sort of
robust against noise well you use the
accuracy so your accuracy here sorry
have you have you added noise to
synthetic data and shown yes we have our
paper I only showed you here without
noise because I want to show the
accuracy the is fundamental
understanding so in some people we do
have a noisy data example the lag
accuracy will be less as expected
nothing to do that so um but there are
other things we do not fully understand
sometimes so the other type of noise
would be if your equation has stochastic
driving it that that will become SD
that's the entire different things that
we have less understanding we won't have
the very first paper just recent wrapped
up I'm not ready to discuss that in
extensive yet we have some understanding
but we have struggle with SC for quite a
long time so okay
uh you said it early in the talk you
said let me see what like if you were
you were talking about uh not having
time as part of the the learned that
question and I thought you meant by that
that you were simply making the markup
assumption that you did not have memory
but then later you introduced memory so
I figured that I misunderstood you
what did you did what did you mean in
the early comments what what I meant is
that we so uh which is the what's the
best what I meant is for example if this
is a new one so let's look at this my
input x and x so we should never have t
as Express input so for example I do not
want
um measure X as a function of T I should
never have t as a node in here okay yeah
and that and that's not the same as
making the Markov assumption that's not
that's not okay it's it it's it's if you
make Market assumption that's true but
it's it's weaker than that
uh but they're all markov's right so uh
anyway just how many steps with memory
is not is not not making the markup or
something but depends on how Define
Markov that this one-stand Marco
multi-stack markets though oh I see yeah
okay yeah
um fine but so
yes well I think I think I think I don't
that's not controversial I just I
understand now what you're what you
meant yeah okay
and and I and and go ahead if there's
any others there are definitely some
others down below yeah um well let I
want to invite the Rob Hayes um he asked
about to know his data but he also he
also asked another questions so Rob if
you want to uphill yourself then
um ask your questions directly that
would be very helpful so it came down to
the the it looked like the the process
you're describing does require each
successive data point to have the same
time step so you're not folding the time
step in you're not mapping it with that
but they do require sequential time
steps to be equal for all okay that's
yeah
we have not work out for simple cases we
can do variable times typing but for
this with memory we can't we we don't
know how to do that yet so it is a
requirement at the moment
got it okay all right um
just
see more are you there
uh yes I am yeah can you ask me a
question directly uh so uh I had a
question regarding just the comparison
with other time series forecasting
methods I was curious if uh the methods
that you propose uh if they are
comparable or are better
than other conventional time series
forecasting methods and if we have time
I have some other questions
about your other papers but it's
probably going to be outside of the
scope of this talks right
um so we didn't do comparison with other
I mean yeah there are a lot of
statistical method to do that uh we
didn't do that compass and I would guess
look this kind of thing is hard to get
without a method like I think
I don't know I'm not aware of the method
can get this kind of accuracy with this
little data over this much long time to
be honest and if you are aware of them
please let me know I would be more than
interested in looking into those methods
okay
but we did I didn't I wasn't aware we
didn't do any comparison so yeah
yeah thank you very much all right
sounds good ah phase out how are you
still there
areas in the fast slogan
all right phase out we heard you
a bit can you
um
volume up
we barely hear you okay
well I I can just ask okay phase out
asked in the fast slow example uh the GT
and your NN do not diverse does it imply
leopardino exponent of zero that's very
nice uh I do not know to be honest
all right uh
Sean are you still there
Sean Smith from Los Alamos
if you're a mask question directly
otherwise I can ask he asked
um the motivation of this approach is
that to use mathematical computational
tools to circumvent the necessity for
physical modeling however definition of
the state space that you rely on is a
large proportion of the physical
modeling even when provided by
experiments
um selecting appropriate instruments
requires insightful physical
understanding
even when the state space is only
partially defined using Mori
chuanzik and the selection of the subset
of the state species in is even more
critical in each of your examples the
state space was defined by a physical
model do you have any comment on that
uh I'm trying to understand so
it's a question is it
if I guess is that about how to select
what variable to to in order to
understand the physics
uh if that's the case I think it's a
slightly different problem right it's an
important problem so a question to ask
even for password observe what variable
I want observe in order to understand
the Dynamics of of the problem and the
this the method here is just assuming
you that's what you observe so the the
the limited case that whatever observes
something that's completely useless I
see nothing happens for example I
observe uh uh for for a moving vehicle I
observe the vertical location of the
vehicle which is zero never changes but
this must suggest that you've given that
data and we produce the prediction zero
uh the vertical location which will
always be zero so which is still correct
but the user is results so I think these
are slightly different problem if I
understand what you ask here so so
identification of the variable to
measure and this is a either important
but a different question here is just If
You observe this we're going to produce
uh predictors which may be used this if
you will observe the use of these
variables I I hope I understand the
question
Sean said Thank you so okay sounds like
yeah you answer them
correctly well I don't see any other
question but I have a couple of
questions here okay no when you you know
when you you know extend your method to
the pde and you gave the nice examples
and how you know gave gave us an Insight
on how to extend your
um FM FML method
you know so you have introduced you know
you can you can do so using some linear
map and but why do you stick with a
linear map you know extend that to you
know non-linear map using the neural net
and spatial I mean this is motivation
yeah yeah yeah exactly right we didn't
use this we just that this thing exists
it's uh let's take this order for less
like let's see it's the worst case a new
one that can do because no one else
would be make everything non-linear so
it's just motivation is is how we
design the network structure based on
this because it's just after no less
than a few thousand testing cases when
nothing really worked consistently which
is trying to find ways to see maybe we
need a structure so we didn't know what
to do so we look into Ola forward type
of thing and then we decided based on
this to design you understand structure
mimicking this
yeah exactly and then you change the D
you know differentiation matrices to
non-linear right functions and by doing
so you are effectively introducing
you know the space which is a lot bigger
than just the linear right it's bigger
than that so it can be a non-meter map
so in some sense the training will be
further than because then you will be
more expensive because now we have the
block thing so input output forget about
this little thing that we have this
parallel layers uh natural layers here
and then this thing goes
is a little bit more involved mostly
because for PE the worker is much longer
that's actually the the Killer part
um right right so when I said uh you
know if I can add in my finishing slide
when I say most of our Network simple
small apply to this case when we do PD
here input one step for this we use
physical with one layer and here we goes
one layer like that like in this thing
it works remarkably well and in our
paper we actually did two layers it's
simply because I told my student look if
you don't do tell two layers people will
ask why don't you go deep Network so
that it's just one layer works fine so
the moment it becomes nonlinear it works
well
okay well I I was wanted to ask you know
there's a that sounds like there's a
trade-off between you know you're making
the training harder but um in some sense
you're increasing the dimension of the
parameter of space so you are hoping
that you will get the better model at
the end in principle we hope that yes
yeah
um so I guess that's the trader
um
you're talking about here oh by the way
the last slide examples uh you said the
pde with the missing
um variable right it looked like a pde
with a missing equations not not the
variable well yeah it's an entire
missing for you but it's a variable
right this is 2500 V 2500 W we're
missing 25 if you think the entire video
has 5000 thing we are missing half of it
so yeah it's amazing variable right but
the first thing is
there a pde equation so the first one
you still have a V and W all of them
together so we just we don't have W here
it's a model of V only
yeah this is only for V there's nothing
you will only observe V we don't have W
whatsoever oh got it oh okay I
misunderstood this slide oh okay yeah
all right
sounds good I'm I'm sure there are more
equipment more questions have I
personally do but I think I can I can
ask that okay if you have interest in
this please feel free to write an email
with I'd be more than happy to discuss
offline I mean online offline to this
talk so I'll be happy to answer any
questions uh is that I mean explore some
possibility to work uh collaborate as
well so that'll be awesome yeah all
right thank you so much all right let's
let's thank our speaker today and uh for
the one that we'll talk and as his
Tongan said hopefully there is a future
collaboration between us all right
sounds good thank you thank you thank
you very much thank you for the invite
okay bye okay bye